[Music]
so this is from a
mutual friend who said one thing that
most people don't know is that his mom
is an md but she stayed home and never
practiced medicine she worked at the
front desk of his dad's orthodontic
business which was which was under their
home
and she was wondering you know how these
family dynamics have
shaped who you are today and how you
parent your own children
so that's a big question that could go a
lot of directions i i recognize but i'd
love to hear you to speak to that in any
way that makes sense
so i'd say that that story is partially
true my mom and dad are both doctors and
my mom did practice for a bit but it is
true that when randy my older sister was
born i guess my mom was having a hard
time finding
child care and people who she trusted
enough to raise the kids so she decided
that she wanted to spend more time with
us but my dad's dental office was
attached to the house like you said so
it's just this like magical thing where
my parents both worked super hard
growing up and were great role models in
that way but also like when i got home
from school i could just like throw my
backpack on the couch and run downstairs
and go see them and then my dad was like
be drilling someone's tooth and like
that person was probably not that happy
that i came in and was like hey dad but
uh plenty of stories there and they were
great parents for for for us growing up
they really prioritized family which is
something
that
i definitely took from them and i think
not only did i take it from them
for myself
but it was really meaningful for me
in
basically who i look for as a partner
and priscilla i think is really focused
on this and she obviously has an amazing
career and has way more jobs than i do
in addition to being a parent but the
family orientation is a really big deal
my parents cared that we like achieved
and did great
in in school
but beyond that they didn't really care
what
specific thing we were interested in
they just wanted to expose us to a bunch
of things and then
if we were interested in something
then they would try to kind of push us
to be to become excellent at that thing
but you know my mom was never like
you should go fence
she
was just like you know
like sports are good right like go like
go find some some sport it's like oh you
like fencing it's like all right well
let's get good at that it's like so i
have three sisters and they're all kind
of excellent at very different things
which is it's our family is
i think quite musical
but that's most expressed through randy
who is just an excellent musician and i
guess you can kind of go through the
different siblings i guess i got
computers that seems to have worked out
for you yeah i i think so i'd say
donna's like the intellectual one and
and l has always been the the kind of
most well-rounded and and social and
athletic of us which is you know as i've
grown up and i've kind of gotten even
more into sports it's been really fun
just getting to to kind of see her how
how much she's how much better she is at
me and like skiing and all these and all
these things that we kind of grew up
together doing but no i i think like
that's that's sort of how i hope to
raise our kids is like
yeah
i mean
i i care a lot they're going to be good
at school but like but i also care that
they can get exposed to a lot of
different things and kind of choose the
things that they want to do it's a fun
adventure
one of the things in terms of my
parenting is i try to
no matter what is going on in the day
i i always do bedtime with them
i mean i guess every once in a while i
have to travel although with covet it's
been nice i haven't had to travel that
much so that's
maybe one silver lining of the of the
pandemic the last couple of years but
it's
but basically you know i just take an
hour every day you know we read we like
sing we you know it's um you know i'm
i'm reading this book with them now the
way of the warrior kid which is is is
good i recommend it a second is this
jocko it is this is jocko willing look
at that
that's great do you know him too
so jocko's first ever long-form public
interview is on this podcast okay there
you go
yeah so i know jacob very well
so this book was recommended to me by
toby ludge the founder and ceo of
shopify
and the girls love it and now they've
started training jiu jitsu so this is
the stuff you know takes on a life of
its own but it's super fun just having
stuff that we do together every day and
then i always you know wrap up the day
with them
we have this routine
that um that max calls the good night
things which is basically every night we
go through i'm like all right what are
the things that are most important in
life and we go through it it's like it's
health loving family and friends and
something you're excited about
and like what did you do to help someone
today and and we basically go through
each of these things and it's like all
right so health it's like well what did
you do to like make yourself stronger
more fit today and like if you're if you
get hurt right it's like
max broke her leg skiing once and it's
like okay well like let's go through the
parts of your body that like still work
and that you're gonna like be able to
use while you're recovering and it's
like okay loving family and friends it's
like let's go through you know something
that you did today with a person who is
meaningful to you and then
i think something you're excited about
is and this is actually this is like my
philosophy on life i'm just trying to
like boil it down for them i guess the
the adult version of this is i think you
have to have something that you're
looking forward to for the future i
think that's just a really important
part of keeping people going with the
weight of life but for kids you know it
tends to be something that they're
excited about tomorrow you know more
more often than not it's just like all
right i'm excited to see mom in the
morning or like i could eat cheerios at
breakfast it's like okay it's not not
super inspiring but um but
the right basic idea and then every once
in a while it's something like okay like
max is like i'm gonna get ski poles next
week and it's like okay that's like a
big milestone right or it's like i'm
gonna lose my first tooth right or like
i can't wait until i can like have do
jiu jitsu again
and then the last one i think is
probably the most important which is
like i'm like
we
you know i think especially for our
family but especially for for these
girls who are obviously growing up and
very wealthy family it's like you're
going to do something nice to help
someone every day right and it's like we
like this is just like an important
service orientation that i just want
you know our our family to have and we
just all go around and like i tell them
something nice that i tried to do to
help someone and and they have to tell
me something nice that they did to help
someone and it could just be like a
another kid at school or it could be
mom or
or um cousin or or something like that
but probably much to their chagrin i
don't let them go to sleep until they
can tell me something that nice that
they did to help someone that day so
that's probably like the best
encapsulation of how i think about
parenting and the values that i want to
try to impart to them
you